- What's happening now in the
United States is very similar
to what happened to Detroit
at the Industrial Revolution,
right, which is that
you're seeing this change
from industrial to digital.
And Miami is the only city
in America that got the memo
and has basically built
its entire economy
to capitalize on what I call
a tsunami of opportunity.
And cities like New
York and San Francisco
and Silicon Valley thought
they were too big to fail,
and I'll tell you,
Dave, they're not.
The world is more
disruptive than ever.
Companies that are massive
get disrupted out of existence
(snaps fingers)
like that.
- Yep.
- And we are building
for the future, and
it's exciting to see.
(downbeat music)
- All right, I'm Dave Ruben.
We are at the Local
Studio here in Miami.
- Yes, yes.
- And I am with the mayor
of Miami, Francis
Suarez, who loves Miami.
Fair to say you love Miami?
Nobody loves Miami.
Everyone loves Miami, but
like you love, love Miami.
- There's no separation
between me and Miami, right.
Like, first of all,
just coming here
and seeing this incredible
studio in the heart of Wynwood
in Miami, which is one
of the most dynamic,
fun, exciting neighborhoods,
it's totally on
brand for you, right.
And, you know, it's just
exciting to see you here,
and we totally embrace what
you're doing, you know,
in terms of the content,
the conversations
that you're provoking,
and it's very much in line
with who we are as a city.
So it's just fun and
exciting to be here.
- So I asked my guys
right before we started.
I sat down with you in
Miami Beach in June of 2021.
- That's right, almost a year.
- So it's about a little less
than a year and a half ago.
I was not a Floridian.
I was not really
thinking about Florida.
There was a little
bit of it, kind of.
- A flicker, there
was a flicker.
- There was a little something,
but a lot has changed
for me in this company.
And you're basically
in charge of the city
that everyone is
coming to right now.
How do you feel about that?
Because I know it's good,
but it also comes with some
stuff that's tough, right.
- Sure, so look, first of all,
as the first mayor of Miami
that was born in Miami, right,
in the 125 year history
of Miami, this is
a dream come true.
I feel like every day
I'm living a dream
in so far as I was born
here, I grew up here,
went to college
here, law school.
- Your dad was mayor here.
- My dad was a mayor from
when I was eight years old
to when I was 16, so I
saw this sort of evolution
of the city very up close.
And to be in a situation
where we have set up a city
to be successful when
a lot of urban cities
in America are not
successful or failing,
and we did it because we
followed three simple rules.
We keep taxes low,
we keep people safe,
and we lean into innovation.
So you know, we have created
a city that's number one
in tech job growth, right.
Number one in wage growth.
We have a city that, because
we've kept taxes low,
has grown 12%, which is the
second most in recorded history.
And with all that
additional revenue,
even though you lower taxes,
you actually have
more revenue, right.
You know, spoiler alert for
New York and California.
(Dave laughs)
Right, we have actually
done the opposite
of what other cities have done,
which have defunded
their police.
We've increased funding for
police, more officers than ever.
Another shocking correlation.
Our crime is about to be,
God-willing, you know,
I knock on wood.
- We're right there, yeah.
- We're not in December yet,
but we are on the precipice
of having the lowest per capita
homicide rate in history.
- Yeah.
- So, it's exciting time
to be here in Miami.
So much has changed in
the last year and a half.
- And it's everywhere in
Miami, not just right here,
because although I don't
want to say the specific part
of town that I
live in, you know,
and in the area that I live in,
there hasn't been a home
break in in 14 years.
I mean the flourishing
is, every day I wake up
and there's a new Los
Angelino coming to my town.
Now, I'm starting to worry, but.
- And I've been in an
elected office for 13 years,
so maybe there's a correlation
(Dave laughs)
between the 14 and the 13.
But look, I think you're right.
Miami was the best kept
secret, number one.
Number two, Miami
has always punched
above its weight, right.
When you think about
what is Miami, I mean,
you could arguably have
someone who lives in Palm Beach
who is in Paris and they ask
them, "Where are you from?"
They say Miami.
- Yeah.
- Like, just sort of
this big thing, right.
I always say Miami's an idea.
It's more than a city.
And it's an idea
born out of a trauma.
What's the trauma?
The trauma is many people
in Miami were kicked
out of their country
of birth, were exiled
because a leader in
their country said,
"Give me all your businesses.
"Give me all your property.
"Don't worry, we'll
make everything equal."
And you know what they did?
They made everything equal.
- Yeah.
- Equally miserable
for everybody,
right.
(Dave laughs)
And so we are
traumatized by that.
And I think that's
why Miamians are
so fundamentally pro-America.
We're so fundamentally
pro, you know,
sort of fair market
and free market.
And we believe in freedom
and liberty, right.
Those are principles that
for us, we fought for, right.
We've been, my grandfather
was in jail in Cuba.
His brother died in a
Cuban jail, you know.
It's very, very real for us.
- So on the tax side,
you wrote a piece
in Wall Street
Journal about a month
or month and a half ago
talking about free markets
and capitalism and why
this place is thriving.
So how does it make any sense?
I thought you need, the
government just needs more
of our money to
make things work,
but you're keeping taxes low.
And we don't have, you know,
roads exploding and
all sorts of stuff.
- Yeah, it's so
counterintuitive.
- How is it possible?
How is it possible?
- So let's,
let me give you a
real example, right.
If you are living in
New York City right now,
cost of living differential
between New York
and Miami is two to one.
So in New York, the median home
price is a million dollars.
In Miami, median home price
is 540, two to one, right.
In addition to that, in
New York, you're paying,
if you're in the
highest tax bracket,
a lot of New Yorkers are,
because again, your
cost of living.
- Well they're all
coming down here now
- Well, but check it out.
Let's do the math, right.
- Yeah.
- You're paying 54 cents out
of every dollar in taxes.
That means that for
every dollar you earn,
you take home 46 cents.
In Miami, you get
63 cents, right.
It is a huge delta, right.
And so that, when you,
at scale obviously is
incredibly motivating to people.
You know, I've seen statistics
that 70% of the taxes
in New York are paid
by 8,000 people.
And if that becomes
7,500 and 7,000, 6,500,
you get what's called
a vicious cycle, right.
You get massive
holes in your budget
when those people leave.
And there's only one way to
get more revenue for them,
which is to increase taxes,
which creates more migration.
- Yep.
- More holes,
and I call it the death spiral.
So what's happening now in the
United States is very similar
to what happened to Detroit
at the Industrial Revolution,
right, which is that
you're seeing this change
from industrial to digital,
and Miami is the only city
in America that got the memo
and has basically built
its entire economy
to capitalize on what I
call tsunami of opportunity.
And cities like New
York and San Francisco
and Silicon Valley thought
they were too big to fail.
And I'll tell you,
Dave, they're not.
The world is more
disruptive than ever.
Companies that are massive
get disrupted out of existence
(snaps fingers)
like that.
- Yep.
- And we are building
for the future,
and it's exciting to see.
- Do you get any pushback from
other mayors who are going,
"Hey Francis, you know,
if you keep taxes low,
"it's gonna make us look
like a bunch of idiots,
"because we got the
grift going here.
"and it's kind of working until
it doesn't work, obviously."
- You know, I'll tell you this,
I'm president of the US
conference of Mayors,
so I'm president of all
the mayors in the country.
And what I get more of,
and I gotta be careful
how I say this, is
I get more of the,
"Camera's not on, listen,
"we really think what
you're doing is great."
- [Dave] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "But we don't have
the ability to do it."
It's, that's more the sentiment
that I get, right, which is.
- So why would a mayor or
not have the abilities?
Because of the local?
- I think there's a
variety of reasons.
I think they get a lot of
pressure from the press, right,
which has this, their
own agenda, right,
Which is a grow government,
government is a solver
of every problem agenda.
I think they've gotta
deal with institutions.
Like for example, when I
first got elected in 2009,
I was the only candidate
elected without union support
because I wouldn't lie to
the unions and tell them,
"Look, we're gonna
raise your pay
"when we're in a recession,
right, you know."
And when we have to cut 20%
of our budget in one year,
which is another thing
that's another lie, right,
which is that government
can't balance its budget.
Listen, I had to cut 20%
from my budget in one year,
$150 million out of a
$600 million budget.
If I can cut 20% in one year,
we can balance our budget
at the federal level.
- And the city
didn't fall apart.
- And the city, no,
on the contrary,
it started thriving, right.
So we balanced our budget.
We were at 13
million in reserves
at the time, 2009 in November.
Now we're at 150
million reserves,
the most reserves
we've ever had.
We have the highest bond rating
under my administration ever
in the history of the city,
which is double A plus,
one away from the highest,
which is triple A.
So we're incredibly
fiscally sound.
And it's all by just, you know,
sort of following
the same formula
that you would if you're
a homeowner, right.
Like in your own personal,
save a little bit of money,
pay off your credit
cards, you know,
pay your debt, don't
overspend, right.
And then spend
strategically on the things
that are gonna make
you more successful.
Invest in yourself,
invest in, you know,
policing, keeping people
safe, that kind of thing.
- What kind of pushback do you
get from the Democrats here
when you're doing
some of these things?
So you're lowering taxes.
- Yeah.
- You're putting
police on the street.
I mean, one thing for sure
that I notice here is that
when I go to New York and I
see cops all over the place,
to me, it's a sign that
something is not right.
- Right.
- When I go here
and I see cops, whether
it's in South Beach
or down where I am, it's
like, "Oh, they're patrolling
"and just making sure
everything's okay."
It's a huge difference
in mentality.
- Yeah, and I think
the other difference
in mentality is we
support them, right.
I think, in other cities,
they don't feel supported.
- Yeah.
- What you gotta understand
is, right now in America,
being a police officer is
the hardest job in America.
It's harder than
being a roofer, okay.
You've got, there
isn't a job in America
where you get paid less
money with more scrutiny
and more risk, right,
and more at stake
and then being asked
to do more things,
because now they're being
asked to be social workers.
I mean, it's really, really hard
to be a police
officer in America.
And I think
fundamentally, number one,
they need to be protected.
They need to be sort
of supported, right.
Number two, they need
to be well paid, right.
Like anybody in life, right,
you've got to support
them financially
because they've gotta
take care of their kids.
They want their kids to go
to school just like you do.
And so we've been blessed.
And then you have to have
a lot of police officers
because it creates
a deterrent effect.
We've given them a ton
of technology to be,
to help them leverage
their, you know,
their sort of force multiplier.
And all of that has been
incredibly successful
in maintaining our
homicide rate where it is.
- What are some of the stresses
of having all these
people move here?
I mean, house prices for sure.
You mentioned they're
lower than New York,
but it's tough to
get a place here.
And one of the things
I'm always worried about,
and I see emails from
this, is that people
that are the OG Floridians
- Sure.
- Who have done it right and
lived here for a long time,
they're suddenly feeling,
"Oh, we could get priced out
"because all of these rich
people from LA and New York,
"et cetera, are coming."
- Yeah, look, it's, we are a
victim of our success, right.
- Yeah.
- What happens is,
first of all, you have
historic inflation.
So here's a problem
with government saying,
"We're gonna solve
the inflation crisis
"by giving everybody
money, right."
So you're in a level where
we're at historic inflation.
If you look at urban America
right now, not just Miami,
urban America, rents
are up 25% or more
in every urban city,
big city in America.
Miami's more like 35, 45%.
Why?
Because you layer on top
of that a hyper demand.
We're all, people are just
fleeing, getting the heck
out of places where they
think they're not wanted
or where they think they're
getting taxed to death
or where they think the
economy is moving away from.
So you have.
- I know the feeling.
- You have all these
things happening, right.
And so there, that is definitely
putting pressure on Miami.
No doubt about it.
I would be lying if I didn't
say that were the case.
But what makes us different,
and why will we thrive in
the face of that stress?
Couple of things.
One is New York is
completely built out.
I think they built the last
building in Park Avenue
in the last 50 years,
just got built, right.
San Francisco's
artificially constrained,
right, with their zoning code.
Miami has the
ability to grow 10 X.
We're in a
neighborhood right now,
Wynwood, which has
explosive growth.
You see it when
you walk out here.
- You can feel it here.
- You can feel it.
- It's ready to have, yeah.
- We have the ability to grow
the delta between what's built
and what can be built
as a 10 to one multiple.
So we can supply ourselves
at a level where, you know,
where we can keep
prices relatively low.
We have, just to give
you some numbers,
about 185,000 dwelling
units in the city proper.
In the pipeline
right now to be built
in the next 24 to 36 months,
we have 47,000 dwelling units.
So that's a 25% increase in
our entire building stock.
So that's number one.
Number two, we do
affordable housing
in a way that is sort of
private sector oriented.
We do the carrot
approach, not the stick.
We don't tell tell developers,
"This is what you have to do."
We tell developers,
"Look, we wanna be a part
of your capital stack.
"We will do, you know,
we'll give you a dollar
"for every $15 that
you invest in a project
"or every $20 you
invest in a project,
"and the only caveat for
our dollar is you gotta
"maintain rent at
a certain level
"for a certain period of time."
That's it, it's a carrot.
You want the carrot, this is
what you gotta do to get it.
If you don't want it, it's okay.
We're not gonna force you.
- So they can build either way.
- Absolutely, a hundred percent.
- Oh, that's interesting.
- They can do market.
Or if they wanna do
something different,
they can do affordable housing.
And we have built, and
we will build probably
between four and a
half and $6 billion
of affordable housing over
the next five to 10 years here
in Miami, in addition
to the supply.
- Can you also talk about
the homeless situation,
because there basically
isn't a homeless situation,
at least compared to
other major cities.
So Florida, it's pretty nice.
Seems like people would want
to come down here, right, so.
- Don't give any ideas.
- Yeah, no, no.
I mean, what have you done?
- I'm sure a lot of
them watch your podcast.
- Yeah.
(Dave and Francis laugh)
20% Of my audience is homeless.
- So look, we're blessed.
We have systematically invested,
and we did it in a way that
was really smart, right.
So we have something
called the homeless trust,
and it is a tax, right.
We don't like to pay taxes,
but this is a tourist tax.
So this is for
people who are coming
to Miami, staying in hotels.
They pay 1% on
their bill, right,
and it funds a homeless trust.
So basically our visitors,
not our residents,
are paying this tax.
Our visitors are basically
paying a tax that goes
to help what I call the
least, the last, and the lost,
the most marginalized
in our community.
And so, you know,
what have we done?
We built a decentralized
set of centers
that give them alcohol
treatment, drug treatment,
mental health treatment, and
vocational training, right.
In addition to that,
we're spending over
the next two years,
about $7 million in a plan
that I call functional Zero.
So we have 640
homeless right now.
6-4-0, according to our
last census, that's it.
- That's it?
- That's it, that's it.
- Wow.
- But I wanna be at zero
because I don't think any
city in America has really,
big city, has really challenged
themselves to get to zero.
And I think that if
we create a model,
then it can be certainly
exported, right,
to the rest of the
country that are dealing
with tens of thousands of
homeless in their cities.
- Yeah, and again, this
is one of those things
where I just see
these other mayors.
It's like, "Why
don't you just look
"at Miami and fix things?"
I went to Denver.
- Yeah.
- I did not, you know,
Denver is not San Francisco.
- Yeah.
- Denver is not LA.
- [Francis] I love
the mayor of Denver.
- Yeah, but I was like,
"But what's going on here?"
- Look, I think, I had a mayor,
and I won't say who it was,
from a big city, one of the,
one of the top 20 cities
in America, tell me recently,
"We just waited too long.
"You know, we didn't
do what you guys did.
"We used to have 9,000 homeless.
"We brought it from 9,000
to a thousand, right.
"And a thousand
is in the county,
"which is 2.8 million people.
"Only about 600 of
that thousand is
"in the actual city proper,
which is my jurisdiction."
So we did it through this
decentralized network.
A lot of these cities
just didn't do it.
And then of course, we're
seeing a lot of mismanagement,
a lot of, I mean, I've
heard some crazy statistics
in California where people
are paying like four
or $500,000 a homeless
or something like that.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's just money that's,
there's no controls.
It's rife with, you know,
a variety of problems.
And so that obviously
is not gonna work.
- Let's talk a little bit
about the hurricane situation.
- Sure.
- Because obviously,
it ended up a hurricane,
and it ended up hitting
Southwest Florida.
We're obviously in
southeast Florida,
but at first it
was gonna hit here.
- [Francis] Yeah, yep.
- Obviously hurricanes
do hit Miami.
- Yeah.
- You've been,
you've been tweeting about it
and doing all sorts of stuff.
What do we need to know for
the Miami and the future
of Miami and who's gonna
come down here or to Florida
in general when it comes to
these storms and all this stuff?
- So to be honest, and
I'm, you know, again,
as president of the US
Conference of Mayors, I was,
I led a delegation
to the Gulf Coast
to see all the cities
that were impacted
in the Gulf Coast, and
it was devastating.
And there's two things that I
think everybody needs to know.
Thing number one
is, for every dollar
that we as a community,
as a country,
spend on the front end
in resiliency investment,
we save seven to
$8 on the back end.
I was just at a podcast
today at an interview
where they were saying that
Senator Rubio's advocating
for $33 billion of spending
for hurricane relief.
So my my point is, if we
would've spent 5 billion
on the front end, we could
have potentially saved
25 to 30 billion
on the back end.
- You're talking about
building new structures
and higher buildings, that.
- I'm talking about
things like, I'm talking
about things like urban
reservoirs, pumps,
increased sea walls, you
know, backflow preventers.
These are all the
things that we're doing
in Miami right now, okay.
In Miami, we, post Hurricane
Andrew, which was in 1992,
which was a 200 mile
an hour wind event,
we basically made Miami the
most wind resilient city
on the planet.
Like we're a bunker, right.
The problem now is
water and water volume.
What we've seen in the last
two years are two events that,
frankly, are super frightening.
Ian and Dorian, I dunno
if you remember Dorian
from a couple years ago.
Dorian was a category five
that sat on top of The Bahamas,
never touched continental
US that I'm aware of.
Maybe up north, but certainly
didn't touch Florida.
And it produced 25
foot of storm surge.
So Ian has produced 10
plus foot of storm surge.
You're talking about 25.
So Mother Nature
has just shown us
two massively destructive
events that no city
in the world is
prepared for, you know,
period, full stop.
- Yeah.
- We've gotta start
being creative.
We've gotta start, you know.
One of the great things
about this country is
its innovative spirit,
right, is its ability
to solve problems,
complex problems, right.
You know, we get
thrown challenges.
We solve them.
We're the first country
to invent, you know,
a nuclear bomb during World
War II, right, which obviously,
as heinous as it was, we used
it, and it ended the war.
It could of saved, who
knows what would've happened
if we didn't have
that technology.
We have always been a
country that finds a way
to solve big problems,
and this is a big problem.
And I think, you know, we're
gonna have to really dedicate,
you know, a ton of
resources to try to solve it
because the scale of these
problems are much bigger
than what we've seen before.
- How does that work
related to the city level
versus the state level?
- Yeah.
- I mean, you know how proud
I am to be a Floridian,
but watching Governor DeSantis
just go from every community
every freaking day, and
you could see the media.
The media was doing
what they do with you.
- Sure.
Like when we had,
when we had one day
of water and brickle,
there was one picture.
- Yeah, makes it look like.
- Of some kids getting
outta a club and they,
because they want to use it
against you guys.
- A hundred percent.
- But can you talk a little
bit about how the cities have
to operate with this
stuff versus the,
versus the state, how
you guys work with it?
- Yeah, so I'll give you a sense
of the differences
in our budgets.
We got about a billion
and a half dollars budget.
The state has $110
billion budget,
so it's about a hundred to
one, right, approximately.
So you know, definitely the
state, we need the state.
We also need the
federal government.
Under President
Trump, he had proposed
a $1.5 trillion
infrastructure bill.
What ultimately ended
up getting passed
was a $1.2 trillion
infrastructure bill.
That money, I haven't seen it.
It's like a joke.
I haven't seen penny
of that money yet, so.
- Have you, have
you called anybody?
- Oh yeah, I would've
called a bunch of people.
"Like, hey, when is this
thing gonna flow, right?"
- Yeah.
- So I think, but I think, look,
infrastructure is a
legitimate expense
for the federal government
if it's spent properly
and if it doesn't, you know,
produce massive deficits,
which unfortunately
it has, right.
But I think, at the end
of the day, you know,
we need a piece of that money
so that we can spend money
on the front end to, again,
avoid having to spend more
money on the back end.
- How confident are you
that Florida's gonna stay
in good shape like it is?
Obviously, we've got elections
coming in a couple weeks.
You mentioned Senator Rubio,
obviously Governor DeSantis.
I mean, it really feels
like things are functional
here and working.
I mean, to watch those
bridges get rebuilt,
the Pine Island Bridge
and then Sanibel
Causeway in two weeks.
I mean, it's incredible stuff.
But how confident are you
that it's gonna keep kind
of moving in this direction?
- So I'm gonna, I'll
give you the good news
and the, you know, the
worrisome news, right.
So the good news is
that Trump won Florida
by a hundred thousand votes
in 16 and 400,000 votes in 20.
So the trend is favorable.
In addition to that,
Republicans for the first time,
I think, in history or
maybe in like 40 years,
outnumbered Democrats, right.
So I think it's
about 250,000 votes.
- Yeah, something like that.
- As of the last time
I looked at it.
So that's the good news, right.
So all that indicates
strength for Republicans.
Republicans should
win at all level.
2018, which was the
last election, like
this was very close.
The governor, I think
won by 35,000 votes.
Senator Scott won by
like 14,000 votes.
And in that same election, a
Democrat won statewide, right.
So that just, which goes to show
just the variability of Florida.
The worrisome news is
that, in Florida, there,
and people don't
talk about this,
I don't know why they don't
talk about it, but they should.
There's 20 to 25% of the
entire electorate is NPA.
It's a huge number, right.
- Wait, NPA?
- No party affiliation.
- Oh, no, okay.
- Right, so they're not
Republicans or Democrats.
- Yeah.
- So when you're
talking about, you know,
4 million people that are NPA,
if 50% of them vote,
that's 2 million votes.
So you could win Republicans
by 250,000 votes,
but the NPAs gotta drop, dry,
they've gotta break your way.
- Yeah.
- Right, and so that's,
if somehow something
bad happens,
I guarantee you that would
be why it would happen.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, we'll see.
I think, I think.
- What do you do to
get those people?
I mean, I guess you just.
- Look.
- Keep making it work.
- Yeah, you keep making it work.
I think a lot of those people,
even in a county
like Dade County,
which is a predominantly
Democrat county, right.
I'll give you an
example of something
that the former
president did, right.
He lost Dade County
in 16 by 30 votes,
30%, I'm sorry, right.
And he only lost it in 20 by 8%.
So when you talk
about that increase
from a hundred
thousand to 400,000,
it almost comes exactly
back to Dade County
because it's the 22% delta
on 1,200,000 voters, right.
So what did he do?
He was strong in
Venezuela, right.
He was bold, and he
recognized Guaido
and got a coalition of countries
to recognize Juan Guaido
to try to disrupt
the Maduro regime.
What did he do on Cuba?
He rolled back all the
Obama giveaways, right.
During Obama's
presidency he wanted,
he wanted a legacy victory,
kind of like Nixon's
China opening, right,
with Cuba and putting
an embassy there.
And we got nothing
in return, right.
Trump undid that.
So 75% of new arrival Cubans
voted for Donald Trump.
- Yeah, it's really
fascinating, I mean, that they,
these people know
it and they get it.
- Of course, no other issues
that are near and dear
to their heart, so
when someone speaks
to those issues, people
are loyal about it.
- So we're gonna,
in a little bit,
we're gonna bring in Assaf,
who's the CEO of Locals.
But I just wanna talk to
you broadly on the tech side
before we talk about
what we're doing.
- Sure.
- So you brought
in all these tech, well
you brought them in.
I mean, basically you sent
out a tweet, you said,
"How can I help?"
- Yeah.
- Next thing you know, all
these tech people show up.
We've talked about this a
little bit once or twice before,
but you know, there's
always the fear
from the original Floridians.
"Oh, they're gonna bring
all the bad ideas."
- Sure.
- What do you think?
- Well, I'll say two things.
One is, it was a counter
narrative, right.
What was happening
in American cities?
New York pushed out
Amazon after HQ2.
- Yep.
- And people don't realize,
it's not just that
you're pushing
out 50,000 high
paying jobs, right.
It's the signaling effect.
What are you telling
your own residents
that you're taxing to death?
Things aren't gonna get better.
We don't want you here.
Get outta here because
we don't value people
who achieve the American dream.
California, F Elon Musk.
Elon says, "Message
received, I'm outta here."
Same thing.
You're not only losing the
world's richest person, frankly,
you're losing something
much worse than that.
You're losing the jobs
from those companies.
You're, again, signaling effect.
We don't want you here
if you're successful,
which to me is an
anti-American sentiment.
When somebody says,
"Hey, what if we move
Silicon Valley to Miami?"
And I respond, "How can I help?"
What am I saying?
I love this country.
I'm saying, "I want
you to be successful."
I'm saying, "I want my
residents to be successful."
And I think what happens is
the media feeds our residents
one thing and one thing only,
government is here to help
you on the expense side.
We're here to give you housing.
Or we're here to give you,
you know, transportation.
And I unlocked something
that I thought was
counterintuitive.
And by the way,
didn't, you know,
the press sometimes giving
me a hard time about it,
which is I want to help you
fish, not just give you a fish.
I wanna teach you how to fish.
I want you to be empowered.
I want all my residents to
get the best paying jobs
to be able to provide
for their families
so that they don't need
an affordable house,
affordable housing apartment,
that they can buy whatever
apartment they want,
that their kids could go
to good schools, you know.
I want my people
to be successful.
And I think, I don't know why
that's controversial at times.
- Yeah.
- You know, I get,
I get criticized
because it's like,
"Oh, but you don't care about."
No, I do, I care.
I've spent 12 years of my life
building affordable housing
and mass transit,
free, you know,
trolley systems in our city.
Now I want people
to be successful,
and I spend a lot of my time
and energy on that, you know.
In terms of some
people who find that,
find it harder for
them, you know,
my heart goes out to them
because obviously
you want everybody
to be successful
and you want people
to embrace the competitive
scenario that we're in.
But it reminds me
a little bit of,
I dunno if you ever saw
the movie Primary Colors.
- Yeah, I saw it 20
years ago or something.
- Anyway.
- I know it's the Hillary.
- Yeah, there's a scene
where the Clinton characters,
John Travolta actually
says, you know,
"I'm gonna do something
very outrageous.
"I'm gonna tell you
the truth, by the way.
"I don't know how
many times that's."
But anyways, and what
he says is he's telling
a union organization
that he, that the jobs
that left that factory
are never coming back,
but that what he said was
that he's gonna teach them
to exercise a different
set of muscles,
the one between
their ears, right.
And I think as our economy
becomes more digital,
unfortunately the economy
that we're gonna be living
in is gonna be more
experiential, content-based,
and it's gonna be
more technological.
So we're gonna have to get
better, and in getting better,
we're gonna, we're gonna
thrive, God willing.
- How at odds do you
feel like you are
with the current administration?
- Well, I think we're at
odds on a lot of issues.
Look, we're in odds on
government spending, right.
They've created this inflation.
Now in California, they're
giving thousand dollars
in anti-inflation, which is
gonna create more inflation,
so they've created inflation.
- They always raise the taxes
and then they give
you your money back,
and you're supposed
to thank them for it.
- Exactly.
- Isn't that something?
- And by the way, it just
creates inflation, right.
So you've got more inflation.
So you've got, you know,
dysfunctional foreign policy,
disastrous retreat
in Afghanistan,
conventional war in Ukraine,
which obviously
this administration
wasn't able to avoid.
You know, you've got this oil
situation in the entire world,
right, where you have oil
prices that are dependent
on foreign producers, the
dependency of Europe on Russia.
You've got South America
going socialist more and more
and the US having no
coherent policy on that.
You know, we have systematically
ignored Cuba's role
as the head of the snake in
exporting its only commodity,
which is communism, and
doing it very effectively
because they were trained by
the Russians in the 1970s.
And, you know, they're
supply chain issues.
I mean, they have really
not confronted successfully,
in my opinion, any of the macro
issues that are generational
in nature or that are gonna set
up this country for success.
- Where are you at on the
immigration stuff, generally?
Obviously, we had this big thing
with the Martha's Vineyard.
- Sure.
- That whole thing.
I don't even really know
actually how the city falls
on when people just show
up here and all that stuff.
- Yeah, look, I mean, we're
a city of immigrants, right.
Mostly legal immigrants,
frankly, because, you know,
Cubans had a favorable
immigration policy
called wet foot, dry foot,
and what preceded it.
So you were able to get asylum
essentially automatically.
I just don't think we're having
a very coherent conversation
about it, you know,
on both sides,
right.
- Yeah.
- I think when you look
at a city like Miami,
we have 1.4% unemployment.
That's awesome.
Until you wanna start,
until you wanna start
a small business,
and then you can't
find employees.
- Yeah.
- Right, so the beauty of us,
of America versus
China, for example,
is we both have
declining birth rates,
and the difference is
nobody wants to go to China.
Everybody wants to come here.
So I think that's an opportunity
if we have a conversation
that benefits the US, right.
As opposed to just a
border conversation, right.
And I think that's
where I hope the future
of this conversation goes,
because this is an
unresolved issue that is not,
it reminds me of World
War I trench warfare.
Everybody's sort of in their
side just gonna poke up.
Ba, Ba, Ba, Ba, Ba.
They get back in
and then, you know,
in a year they maybe
move four inches, right.
So there's just no coherent
discussion on it in my opinion.
- So what, so what
do we do in Miami?
Like what's the policy if
somehow illegals get here?
- Yeah.
- I'm not even sure
where the Martha's
Vineyard one started
or how they ended
up roughly here.
- Yeah.
- But what,
but what is the
city's policy on it?
- Well, we don't, we don't,
we're not ICE, right.
So we don't have a formal role.
So that's an ICE issue, right.
The federal government
immigration's custom enforcement
issue as to whether or
not, how they detain people
and what they do with them
once they're detained.
So we don't have a role in that.
We don't, we don't get in
their way either, you know.
We sort of let them do their job
and support them if
and when necessary.
But you know, again, part
of what makes us special
is our diversity,
right, and our inclusion
in terms of a variety of
different people that come
from a variety of
different backgrounds,
and it's what makes
us who we are.
So I also think for
the Republican party,
I think this is important.
Hispanics are trending
Republican, right.
And I think it, why are,
why is that happening?
In part because
Democrats don't know
how to speak to them, right.
They either call them Latinx.
- I was, you're not Latinks?
Come on, what are we doing.
- Which does not resonate
when you go macro,
right, when you.
And then when you go nuanced,
you call them a San
Antonio taco, right.
So they don't get
the macro branding,
they don't get the
nuance branding.
And I think this is
an awesome opportunity
for Republicans to say,
"Hey, we respect you.
"We know you want
to be Americans.
"We know you're law abiding.
"We know that you believe
in family and you want to,
"you know, you believe in
the family unit as a means
"of trying to get people to
be successful and education."
These are all of the things
that Republicans always
talk about, right.
So you know, there's a
great opportunity there
to lean into that and not be
worried that if, you know,
something happens on
the immigration front,
it's gonna be damaging
to Republicans.
It actually might
be very beneficial.
- You mean you're
telling me that Latinos,
just like everyone else, care
about more than one issue?
- They do.
- Isn't that wild?
- And they care
about our country.
- Very bizarre.
Let me ask you one that I saw.
- By the way, look
at what's happening
at the Southern Texas border
in congressional races.
- No, it's incredible,
what's going on.
- Republican women that
are gonna hopefully sweep
three congressional races,
one I think they hadn't held
for 150 years or something.
- Mayra Flores.
- Mayra Flores, yeah.
- And she's the one that
then the New York Times ran
the article, what was it?
The Latino face
of the new right,
or something, or the alt-right.
- There you go.
- Something insane.
Let me ask you one
about, that I saw some
of my guys giving
you some crap for,
which is some of the
gun buyback stuff.
- Yeah.
- And this thing.
So I saw my more
conservative side going,
"He's coming for guns,
he's a Democrat,"
something like that.
So I allow you to clean
it up however you see fit.
- Well, first of all, I think.
- People that like you generally
that live in this city.
- Yeah, no, and I think,
and hey, I'll tell you this.
Let's see how I put this sort
of a little bit delicately,
right.
- Yeah.
There's a lot of jockeying
going on right now,
and there's a lot of
surrogates that are doing a lot
of things to try to build
people up and tear people down,
you know, kill them in
the crib type of thing.
There's a lot of that happening
with me as my
profile gets bigger,
as I get talked about in
more prominent circles.
It's more like, "Hey,
let's try to brand him
"as a certain thing, right."
And there's a lot of
that happening with me.
But, you know, gun
buy back is something
that the city's been
doing forever, right.
And it's not about, you know,
being pro-gun or anti-gun.
I'm fervently
pro-Second Amendment.
I'm a gun owner and
incredibly pro-police.
I think really more,
it's more for, you know,
what happens oftentimes
is like a widow,
right, whose husband passes,
and the husband was
an avid gun collector,
and they have 20,
30 guns at home,
and they're afraid that
if somebody breaks in,
they're gonna steal the guns
and kill them or
hurt somebody else.
So they just don't feel
safe with the guns at home,
and they prefer to sell it.
These, you know, these
oftentimes are elderly people
who are living on
fixed income, right.
And they get, we have
like, what do you call it,
coupons that we give
them, or you know,
I forget what they're called,
sort of a gift cards
that we give them, right.
And so we'll give them gift
cards to Publix or gift cards
to Target or whatever, and
they'd rather have, you know,
$1,500 in gift cards
to target than 20 guns
that they don't know
what they're doing with,
right, in their own home.
So that's the, that's the
prototypical scenario.
So it's not like we want
to take guns off the street
in that sense, or we
want people not to.
It's completely
voluntary, right.
- Right.
- So people wanna
do it, they do it.
If they don't wanna do it,
they don't have to do it.
- Do we even have a gun problem?
I mean, is there, are there
shootings here really?
Like, no.
- So that's the other
thing is that, you know,
in this conversation about
gun violence, people,
it's such a myopic
conversation, right.
We don't talk about the fact
that in Miami, for example,
we have, we were ranked the
happiest city in America,
the healthiest city in
America with 1.4% unemployment
and increasing funding
for police departments.
So it turns out if you
have more police officers,
happy people, healthy people,
and people that are
working, guess what?
They're not killing
other people, right.
So that's the
formula for success.
- The happiness may come
from not being killed.
- And by the way,
that has nothing to do
with whether they own a
gun or don't own a gun.
That has to do with
their frame of mind.
It has to do with where
they, what they are in life.
And I've often said,
"Look, you know,
"if somebody wants to
hurt somebody, there are
"unfortunately a multitude of
ways that that can happen."
And so we've gotta look at the
root cause of why people feel
compelled to do X and
where we're missing.
And I think that gets lost
in the discussion a lot.
- Do you think the
happy part is, I mean,
and literally it's not,
you're not making it up.
I mean, it was voted
the happiest city in
the United States.
- Yeah, multiple
years by the way.
- You can see, you
can see it here.
I mean, people, and it's
not just the weather there.
I think it obviously
is connected
to the spirit of freedom
and all those things.
- And taxes, when
you don't have to pay
so much in taxes,
you're happier, right.
Like, you know, at the end
of the day, we want to look,
I have this concept called
return on time, right.
We think about return
on investment, right.
ROI, right, and
we think about it.
And people don't
realize that their
most precious commodity
is their time, right.
It's the only thing
that we all have
in common that is finite, right.
We can't make more of it.
I mean, we can be healthy
and hopefully, you know.
We have good genetics, you
know, hopefully we live longer,
but we're all
basically conforming
to a life that is a
certain amount of time.
And I think we have
gotta build our city
around that concept.
And if you see the world,
it's going to that concept.
It's experiential, right?
Restaurants, virtual
reality, metaverse.
It's content, podcasts,
YouTube, et cetera.
And then it's sports.
It's, you know, experiential
and parks and things like that.
And that's how you build
a city that I think
really respects people's
most precious commodity.
- On that note, we're gonna
take a ten second break.
We're gonna bring in Assaf,
because a year and a
half ago I said to you,
"I'm thinking about it."
And you said, basically,
"How can I help?"
And here we are.
- And it's happened.
I love it.
- All right.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead
of non-stop yelling, check
out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.